umberto mejia a former marlin five
career starts not a whole lot of luck
yeah owen three five fourteen era lost
his last start against the phillies went
six gave up eight hits and four runs few
quick outs for mahia good start the
pitch is a swing of the miss
and albies is down on strikes and the
braves are easy for me here on the first
stint and one two three
noah he's pitched great just needs some
runs to play with tonight yeah you see
season numbers 14 starts four and five
with the 3-2 last time out against
colorado four and two thirds two earned
runs two walks eight strikeouts
down the line and
fears
as the first base umpire jim wolfe who
had to tap dance out of the way of that
one
and cattell has a double some fancy
footwork down there by jim wolfe
kind of hooks that breaking ball right
down the line
there you go jim wolfe and it's a fair
ball so suddenly the number three hitter
is dalton varshall and based on the way
he's performed lately he deserves to be
there
popped up left side will it stay in play
it appears so riley is there and after
nine pitches varshall is retired for the
second out and here is the freight train
in the cleanup spot david peralta
chopper out towards first friend he's
got it on big balance takes him to the
bag and that is out number three austin
reilly adam duvall and eddie rosario
here in the second inning one two pitch
hard hit ball down the left field line
of fear ball that was right on the line
all the way into the corner having all
sorts of trouble with the peralta big
turnaround second for riley throws on
the brakes and he back pedals to the bag
and that's the lead off double here at
the top of the second inning now duval
will be the hitter a big strike out
there for mejia that's his second so two
on now for swanson
fastball foul tip carson kelly hangs on
that's the third strikeout and a big one
for mejia two outs of the second 2-2
pitch is popped up
out into shallow center varshall comes
on the center fielder and makes a catch
contours is out and the inning is over
noah after 22 pitches in the first time
could use a quick inning
and a check swing and a miss and he noah
breezes through the second on a 97
degree night in phoenix top of the order
hey solaire who grounded the sega to
start tonight's ball game
left it out over the plate marshall runs
it down
two ounce in the third and here comes
freddie freeman
and he shoots one the other way that is
patented freddie freeman
an opposite field single he reaches for
a 17th straight game and the braves have
their second hit that keeps the enemy
live
turned on that one hit it into the
corner freddie around second on his way
to third ramos got to it quickly ozzy on
his way to second he'll stop there back
to back two out hits second and third
two outs and here's riley who doubled
his first time up swing and a shot in
the left center field that's gonna score
two
riley comes through with a two strike
two out hit
91 rbis in the brave strike first
what a second half for riley two doubles
two rbis for riley two-nothing braves
three straight atlanta hits with two
outs and arizona comes right back with a
threat a walk and a single brings up
cattell marte
[Applause]
that's gonna drop in for a base hit
vargas will score rojas coming into
third they'll stop him there
and it's an rbi double for katel marte
they throw it away
and rojas is home
martay is out at third
but the time runs come across
atlanta a little sloppy getting that
ball back in from the right field corner
and that'll allow the extra run to come
in
ozzy had to short hop that one and that
allowed rojas to sneak in now the braves
are going to shift here with the banner
var show marshall sends this one to the
gap and that gets down
all the way to the 4 13 mark varshall
headed for third
dalton versio hayes got the triple
it's a triple for varsha with two men
out here in the third inning so peralta
has the go ahead run down there at third
now with two ounce david grounded out
his first time up
that kicks away not too far
contreras can't pick it up and var shows
home it's 3-2 diamondbacks william
contreras the backup catcher had that
relatively close to home played varsho
stopped halfway thinking it was gonna
have to go back and then the ball rolled
away freddie freeman singled and scored
the first braves run let's see how they
alter their shift with a runner in
scoring position
swing and a shot it is fair into the
corner back-to-back doubles for atlanta
they've got the game tied
if freddy is 79th rbi of the year
what the outfielders are looking for
cover out there those balls are getting
to them in a hurry 3-3 game nobody out
swing and a shot into right center a
base hit freddy on his way to third
they're going to bring him around far
shows throw is cut off ozzy dives into
second three straight atlanta doubles
and the braves are back in front they
had to come way to his left to come get
that ball
freddie was going to score easily
he saw it recognized it
smart base running three straight hits
and austin riley is coming up
swing and a drive deep left center field
at the track at the wall it's off the
wall
late break by ozzy he's chugging home
there'll be no throw it's a three double
night for riley and the braves extend
the lead and adam will face a new
pitcher for the diamondbacks it's taylor
widener
swinging in a drive by duvall
way back in left center how far is that
one going to the concourse
wow a mammoth home run duvall keeps his
hit streak alive and the braves have
blown it open 483 feet adam duvall
that's the second longest atlanta home
run in the stack cast era which is since
2015. milestone homer for duvall and the
braves have taken a four run lead so
down to third base goes rosario to
second base goes swanson and freed on
with the walk there's so layer
on the ground to third tricky hops
second base one
and a first not in time solar keeps the
inning alive
rosario scores
the braves have a sixth run across in
the fifth inning freddy doubled home
soleir the first of six consecutive hits
in the inning for the braves
on the ground diving stop ball pops away
throw to first throw it away that's
behind the back stop a run is in freeman
and solaire advance martay made a great
stop but then a terrible throw and
another mistake that the braves cash in
braves have scored seven in the fifth
here comes the pitcher spot now and it
looks like jake mccarthy making his way
up there
jake mccarthy hits one deep to right
field
solaire at the wall
that's gone
jake mccarthy a pinch hit homer for his
first big league home run that was a
towering fly ball out of here and he
gets the dive backs a little closer nine
to four brett the gus deals to eddie
rosario there's a 1-0 pitch that is
drill
deep right field and that is way out of
the ballpark
eddie rosario just took the cover off
the ball
that is his second homer in his many
days and for the season that is his 13th
and make it a 10-4 lead and they're at
first and third with two down here at
the top of the ninth inning
and that got away and that's gonna bring
home another run and the braves now have
an 11-4 advantage now the braves a
strike away
on the ground freddie's got it flipped
to santana braves are three up in the
east the magic number is 11.